it's Tuesday mother [ __ ] uncle Joey's
back with a [ __ ] mission you
understand me
mushrooms Gorilla Biscuits refle last
night I'm still here [ __ ] I've
been up since 6:00 a.m. I had a [ __ ]
tension saluting the flag [ __ ]
it's a beautiful day to be alive look at
my boss I went deep with those [ __ ]
shrooms last night we missed the church
you [ __ ] up as usual but that's the
past is the future [ __ ] it's
Tuesday wash your [ __ ] out of that ball
sack we [ __ ] around today we're
taking it to the next level tonight free
tickets this is not happening taping at
the [ __ ] cheetah in Hollywood stinky
[ __ ] Riefler and uncle Joey dropping
knowledge like a [ __ ] but enough
is enough it's that time to get the
[ __ ] party started you understand it
because we're often morning party you
ain't got dick the rest of the day you
float around
I need Starbucks now you know you need
reefer [ __ ] Starbucks is for
[ __ ] that's what [ __ ] but they're
[ __ ] de savages like us me you this
[ __ ] tree
I want to put the weight in case they
sneeze it goes over the bow and then
we're all [ __ ] understand if the lock
rolls over we'll all be dead anyway
uncle Joey here direct feeling good
I did my CBD oil I did my [ __ ] it
smoothly with almond milk are you
[ __ ] nuts all right it's too much if
you're not buddies Joey what's it the
chitter-chatter just park the [ __ ]
boat you're absolutely right amiable
[ __ ] up the last of that [ __ ]
residue from this village
oh yeah look at that
that's a [ __ ] clown you're only with
your friend smoking behind the building
I can't get too high really then go
watch some other [ __ ] podcast and guy
with a weed that - oh my god
I believe this reefer tattoo get the
[ __ ] outta here
well we have [ __ ] walk-in the walk
[ __ ] understand me all these half-ass
[ __ ] out there you people
believe from [ __ ] MMA the [ __ ]
actors we walk the walk [ __ ]
understand me
so strap up a run and get that [ __ ]
pipe ready cause it's Tuesday
[ __ ] uncle Joey [ __ ] around
and guess what
neither of you the skewer of death in
case I gotta stick your [ __ ] eyeball
on a skewer and smoke it feeling good
today we gotta go to acupuncture and
we're meeting a couple golf's
I may go legit - I may not customize a
double date them off my double session
could get you on Wednesday they will
drill class a little class
take a look honestly my man man wait
that is weekend and I said [ __ ]
the beautiful thing is you are here
you're alive in a second she has to be a
bad [ __ ] and you're staring at
me like Joey I don't know get the [ __ ]
out put on a [ __ ] shirt and wash that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and get out there
standing [ __ ] and take him back
with your that's it that's all you need
- that's your [ __ ] mission for the
day you want to be a plumber be a
[ __ ] plump you want to be an
astronaut eight they got schools you
want to be a [ __ ] Camille whatever
the [ __ ] you want to be gives a [ __ ]
giving a shot what the [ __ ] are they
they tell you what you're not gonna be
good at [ __ ] them
oh [ __ ] take her into the next [ __ ]
level here when I'm full Joey
Tuesday morning guiding you through
dying it for some people have a guy to
put together a [ __ ] a [ __ ] table
or a [ __ ] car
and what y'all up there they got a
battery I know you're a bad [ __ ]
but you're saying joy what's my next
move you know your next move
[ __ ] you know your next move
where you ask him before you know what
you need to do but in the meantime we
want to smoke another bowl while you
decide what the [ __ ] you wanna do cuz
that's how we do it here
good morning [ __ ] Johnny understand
this as good as it gets beep nobody's
gonna come you ain't no morning fluffy
show write this you know why everybody's
breaking his balls trying to be cute I
don't give a [ __ ] one of his face even
if I put a pound of makeup on this
[ __ ] I can't do now so I'll need
to be cute I'm just telling you the
[ __ ] realities of life we [ __ ]
push-ups dealing with these [ __ ] Isis
[ __ ]
[Music]
I am the world that hides the universal
secret of all time
I love marijuana and I thought you
people that have
I love smoking briefly I love it there's
nothing like this [ __ ] look along gonna
have to be at a bar with a bunch of jerk
buzz salut get the [ __ ] out of my face
I'm at home so boot myself
I thought you're [ __ ] stoned already I
think I went a little bit ahead of
myself that happens it happens in your
[ __ ] animal you gotta get stoned to
the gills on Tuesday I understand it's
just that bad but they Tuesday is a
[ __ ] up thing if they get to you
savages like us it'll get affected by
Tuesday we put our pants on we put our
pants on only at that time seven days a
week
what do you want to do [ __ ] will
be management criticize me
my skewer falls is to get the math later
anyway that's it that's that
you got your assignment for the day
understand me you know what you need to
do leave to hug the cat the dog call mom
tell her I love her
and everybody else this [ __ ] hoping
game there's a pigeon [ __ ] everywhere
with their wallet ready to give you
Jesus and you're sitting there giggling
with your friends then think a little
gentler at the [ __ ] play before I
[ __ ] slap you got left us anyway nine
o'clock show denied the cheetah if you
come by we'll be there soon so meters
tonight we can [ __ ] them to the hills
remember nobody [ __ ] with you today
nobody had no [ __ ] level your back
[ __ ] across the street kick
your ass meet Rita tree anyway stay
black uncle Joey loves you to church
coming out here tomorrow at eight
o'clock
jae-joon 10 10 11 to Omaha [ __ ]
Nebraska oh [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
Huskers anyway
as you could tell I'm stoned to the
gills have a great damn for Joey loves
you don't take no [ __ ] from nobody stay
black
you